[Music]
that's britney spears bearing it all
like literally rocking nothing but her
birthday suit
brick goes fully nude in a series of
pics and videos from her tropical beach
vacation and while she's the one rocking
the birthday suit the getaway is
actually for her man sam escari special
day he turns 28 later this month it's
amazing it's heaven from here on out
brit is flaunting it all for the camera
including four snaps posing in the clear
waters
cleverly using diamond emojis as sensors
[Music]
the singer also posted this video laying
in the sand and splashing around
[Music]
but don't worry the birthday boy is also
getting in on the fun
sam shared this steamy video of him and
britt getting intimate in a pool
i'm just living my life right now now
the couple may be on vacation but we
know they work hard and play hard just
last week a source told et the engaged
pair is very career focused right now
especially sam and adds that he's really
pursuing all opportunities coming his
way and wants to amp up his persona they
are both going so hard right now and
putting in a lot of work and effort into
all areas of their lives both personally
and professionally my main thing is to
enjoy life
and take today take one day at a time
and i try to live by that of course this
follows britt winning back her freedom
in november when a los angeles judge
ruled to terminate the 13-year
conservatorship that controlled the
singer's life career and finances what's
next for brittany
and this is the first time this could be
said for about a decade
is up to one person brittany turns out
sam's been a major motivating factor in
the grammy winner's latest chapter the
source adds sam's drive and ambition is
empowering she is equally as motivated
and career driven as he is that's their
focus and the path they are on right now
she's doing great i'm great i'm just
it's the happiest time of our lives and
we're just enjoying it and britt's
allegedly getting back to work first up
a book according to multiple reports the
pop star has signed a 15 million dollar
tell-all book deal with simon and
schuster i just want to be a happy
person but careers aside it seems the
two are setting time aside to plan their
dream wedding after getting engaged in
september
look at that
you like it yeah
here's what sam told e.t in november you
have to have some do you want a big
wedding a small one i won the biggest
wedding in the world
what kind of wedding do you want to have
what's your dream day you know it's up
to her she's wearing the pants now
[Music]
you